In Season 3 of "The Mandalorian," Din Djarin
bathes in the Living Waters to restore his
status as Mandalorian.
But his devotion to his clans means fans don't
get a view of everyone's favorite internet daddy.
Spoilers ahead!
Although there are different factions of Mandalorian
people, the one that Din Djarin belongs to
is stringent when it comes to honoring the
old ways of the Mandalorians.
This means that Djarin is expressly forbidden
from removing his helmet in front of any living
being, for doing so would mean expulsion and
excommunication from his clan.
However, Djarin does publicly remove his helmet
a few times throughout "The Mandalorian,"
either to say goodbye to his adopted child
or to save his own life.
Because of these transgressions, Djarin is
forced to bathe in the Living Waters on the
ruined Mandalorian home planet to be readmitted
to his clan.
Mando achieves this goal, and it seems as
if he has taken his renewed vows very seriously.
Djarin is never seen without his helmet throughout
Season 3 of "The Mandalorian," much to the
dismay of fans.
Taking to social media, some fans lamented
that they weren't given a chance to see Djarin
without his helmet with one user tweeting,
"din took his helmet off twice in s2 because
he knew that tin can was staying ON for s3."
Many others agreed when it came to wanting
Djarin to take his helmet off at least once.
On Twitter, a user posted an image of Kermit
the Frog browsing nooses and expressed tremendous
disappointment at not being able to see Djarin's
face.
Likewise, one user wanted to see Djarin as
well and said that his helmet could have at
least fallen off during one of the many fights
throughout Season 3.
These sentiments were also echoed over on
Reddit, where a Redditor started a conversation
by pointing out that this was the first time
Djarin hadn't taken off his helmet for an
entire season.
This statement caused several to reply with
some saying,
"[Yeah] he shoulda had the helmet off at the
very end, just in the background.
I thought they only took it off around family,
would have sold that even better."
Others agreed with that sentiment, thinking
that it would have been a nice touch to solidify
Grogu and Djarin as family.
"Let it be written in song that Din Djarin
is accepting this Foundling as his son."
Another Redditor had their own theory as to
why Djarin never revealed his face this season.
They thought he remained covered because Pedro
Pascal could only do the voice work since
he was also appearing in HBO's "The Last of
Us."
Even though many would love to see Djarin's
face, his spoken creed as a Mandalorian prevents
him from doing so.
But most fans understand why it wasn't an
option for him in Season 3.
As a Twitter user pointed out, the Mandalorian
takes his religion and culture seriously,
and he isn't going to risk being exiled again.
This is especially true after having to go
through so much effort to redeem himself.
Another user agreed, explaining that the bounty
hunter "went to Mandalore for a reason."
Elsewhere, some fans on social media believe
that Djarin keeping his helmet on in the season
finale actually made his enemies seem less
evil.
The Twitter user wrote,
"i was waiting for them to take din's helmet
off to humiliate him when he was captured
but i guess moff gideon isn't as vile as i
expected him to be."
In short, for Djarin to show his face in public
again, he'll need to be captured by a truly
evil foe who not only wants to defeat him
but also wants to humiliate him.
If no villain is willing to sink that low,
then it would take an event so monumental
that Din is willing to risk his status within
the Children of the Watch to show his face
once again.